the gas stove band debate is boiling
over AOC is mocking Republicans who are
concerned with a possible ban despite
having won herself
I do think it's funny that like absolute
utter Republican meltdown where they're
like you can take my gas stove or my
cold dead hands or how dare you talk
about gas stoves you have a gas stove
first of all first of all I rent periods
second of all though it doesn't even
matter because by that logic
these are the same people who would have
said we should have never gotten rid of
leaded gasoline
just because someone may have driven a
gasoline car no secret government agency
is gonna bust down your door and take
your gas stove away
you know a very interesting animation I
see in her Tyrus don't you yeah yeah I
think uh yes there's that Golden Rule
that and if anyone's ever heard this
I'll say it again at home never film
yourself with a good idea when you've
been drinking yeah that looks like
Wednesday night wine night
but terribly wrong and and to say and to
say she's mocking that's a strong World
it has to be clever and funny yeah and
and whenever you do and then they said
and there was no punchliner joke and she
made the weird voice and then you repeat
yourself and first of all and first
first of all that's the that's the wine
burp in between
stop drinking
shoot this Martha I mean I cook with gas
you cook with gas yes I do okay
everybody knows how to cook and wants to
cook hooks with gas I don't know if I
know how to cook but I do cook with gas
okay but but the thing is I think that
she uses a gas stove a lot because if
she thinks it's linked to reduce
cognitive performance then she is proof
positive of that well I would just say
that I don't I don't agree with her that
they're not coming for your gas stove
because they came for our light bulbs
yep they came for the shower head
pressure oh yeah the toilet water
pressure
um so they've already taken all these
things so I I do believe that they are
coming eventually for the gas stove as
well if anyone has ever done a
renovation or built the house you know
that nothing turns out the way that it
used to be it all is like lower power
and this is all government regulated so
there's no reason to think that they're
not coming for the gas station you know
the truth is Geraldo that the nanny
State I mean it's getting to the point
where you've like had enough off
she has a perfect defense and that is
she rents okay the gas stove was in the
property when she rented okay let's
forget about it are you worried about
you yes send somebody with my car but
it's fine I rented it yeah someone on
CNN said it's like oh I haven't yet
stove is like a car idling in your
kitchen I mean
I mean you could do a whole series of
shows about the lack of science attached
to climate change
I I think that it is scandalous to me
how I remember the New York Times very
clearly it was uh purported climate
change uh alleged climate change
possibly climate change then one day
they decided editorially that there was
climate change and it was absolute it
was a it was an ideological
political
decision not assigned okay so I think
it's I think that there's of course
we're concerned of course I think the me
I I think the world's a lot cleaner than
it was when I was a kid I mean La the
when I moved to LA in 63 you could not
see across the freeway thank God for
Gavin Newsom well Jesse Jesse let me get
to you on this thing with the gas stoves
if you're 33 you can't brag about
renting
and that's a shot at her fiancee that's
a low-key shot at the fiance to say you
better put me in a house soon
also her opinion is saying this when the
government comes in and says something
is bad for you
and takes it away from you that's
progress what about Prohibition they
came in and said alcohol is bad they
took all the alcohol away that wasn't
progress AOC and of course we're
paranoid they the government spies on us
they lie to us they probably funded
covid-19 and then they made us get a
shot then left it in the garage and the
stupid water pressure I mean my hair
looks like a good shower water comes out
really strong I need a little volume
part of it is all you need is a vent you
need a fan turn it on and get it open
the window hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else